real question are there people out there
who don't like Ninja Turtles I've
personally never met any I need to know
for science
[Music]
so Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles mute
Mayhem is a new animated Ninja Turtles
film also another example of how
spider-verse has inspired animation and
film though I will say the animation in
the world of mutant Mayhem doesn't feel
like a spider-verse clone inspiration
sure but it does have its own flavor its
own take I appreciate that I will say
this I do think kids will have fun with
this movie the positives being first and
foremost the animation if you're a kid
you're like bright colors and energy
you'll probably be in also like the
soundtrack I thought the soundtrack was
a lot of fun and they had a lot of fun
with it in the film it either adds to a
fight sequence or yes adds to a joke
this movie being a comedy 100 comedy
that gets exhausting for me I like my
Ninja Turtles just to feel badass and
the comedy come through in Parts where
it's warranted this movie does have Seth
Rogen and Evan Goldberg listed among the
writers for this film and you do feel it
it does show it's made for kids until it
might scare the [__] out of them there
are some scenes where I'm like yeah it's
made for is I gotta scare the [__] out
of kids it might it might scare your
kids I mean villains a really big mutant
fly in the movie he's pretty intense
actually he's one of the best parts of
the film no it's not Baxter Stockman
Baxter Stockman was at the beginning of
the film and then hey big mutant fly
who's not Baxter Stockman when that
character the fly his name is Superfly
was originally going to be Baxter
Stockman as seen by the toy the action
figure I don't know why they changed it
maybe just maybe it's because they were
like hey we just wrote this new Ninja
Turtles movie uh yeah Baxter Stockman's
story is a lot like the fly who owns
that fox they won't sue us it'll be fine
change it that is no longer Baxter
Stockman he is now Super Fly we are not
taking on the Empire's IP head-on no but
to be clear I don't know why yes we're
dealing with the world of Ninja Turtles
an IP that has so many mutants you do
not need to make one up for a movie
making up a mutant for a movie of Ninja
Turtles would be like making up a
character to be in a Mortal Kombat movie
oh yeah right in a world where that just
seems like a dumb move they made the
character work I just love it when
movies take an obscure villain and make
that villain cool and yeah Ice Cube was
great voice again at first he seems kind
of cool like he could maybe hang out
with this guy and then he gets intense
when he gets intense it's scary last but
not least this film is 90 minutes long
oh
let's give it credit for that alone it
feels like so long since I've seen a
movie be 90 minutes and be okay with
that I appreciate that about mutant
Mayhem so I can imagine this will land
for kids I imagine they'll find it fun
not a little scary at times as a
professional I should be able to
separate my own mind from that reality
and proceed accordingly
but you clicked on my video for my
opinion so this is what we're gonna do I
call it bitching about trivial [__] that
doesn't matter in the world but I do
YouTube videos so here we go when it
comes to Ninja Turtles can't help it I
do have thoughts and generally it comes
down to the lore and the execution of it
it's kinda not here case in point the
story of the Ninja Turtles in this movie
well it's familiar to a point turtles in
the sewer mutagen ooze they mutate
Splinter mutates however where did they
learn their martial arts where did they
learn the ninjutsu I learned it by
watching movies
course I don't know I saw that I was
like this feels like it was written for
an entire generation that's just done
trying and has no imagination it's like
Hollywood has a different perspective a
different mindset maybe maybe the
audience it does too but so I just don't
connect with it the mindset being the
Ninja Turtles in order for 2023 little
Timmy to relate to them the Ninja
Turtles themselves have to be kids who
don't know martial arts and don't know
Ninjutsu but they just emulate what they
see in martial arts movies like little
Timmy does I would think being a young
Ninja Turtles fan is seeing Ninja
Turtles who don't actually know Ninjutsu
and don't know martial arts they just
emulate what they see on TVs kind of
like the old adage never meet your
Heroes don't make the Ninja Turtles
Steven Seagal that sucks and yeah this
movie has a lot of mutants but it feels
like someone was just like all right
there's a poster of all the mutants
we're gonna have them them them
those two are girls now we good we got
it awesome does it feel like any thought
went into it you have Mondo Gekko
scumbug Genghis frog a lot more and I
feel like they just could have been
anybody Paul Rudd as Mondo Gekko was one
of the ones who stood out more and
couldn't even tell that was Paul Rudd
didn't find out until later but Bebop
and Rocksteady had so much more
personality in that live-action movie
they were in than this film Giancarlo
Esposito is Baxter Stockman he's one of
the greatest castings ever
it's at the very beginning
it's just not in the movie I would say
the actors were wasted but I feel they
did their job perfectly their job being
had the IMDb page for this film there
are more than a couple times in this
movie where the movie
is trying to have a lesson or we'll say
a theme and instead of allowing the
audience to be like hey I see that I see
that I make the connection myself it's
like the movie grows impatient and just
tells the audience the connection
they're supposed to be making it's like
we'll do it for you your brain's the
middleman we're just removing the
middleman which is a bummer because some
of the lessons in the movie are actually
good lessons you know not judging the
group as a whole based on the actions of
a few most people can get behind that
when it comes to their group throw it
out the window when it comes to the
other group but they love that for their
group actually I'm thinking about it the
movie does a lot of tell rather than
show one example is Raphael's rage there
are a lot of references to Raphael's
rage a lot of jokes about Raphael's rage
but he never actually feels like he has
emotional rage it's a nod and a wink
that the characters give to the audience
because we know he's supposed to have
that so at that point it's just it's a
reference and I feel the emotional tones
this movie was going for were buried
under the weight of the comedy because
this movie is absolutely a comedy not
that comedies can't have emotional
moments that land I just feel in this
movie in particular they didn't because
they didn't balance the two elements out
and how the movie wraps up we're talking
the very end then cut to credits that
moment I didn't like it it didn't feel
like Ninja Turtles to me look like I
said if you have kids they're probably
gonna have a lot of fun with this film
except when Splinter made out with
scumbug
that was just gross at any age
spoilers it's fast-paced funny with
eye-catching animation but I don't have
kids and for me I think this movie would
be a better time if you're drunk yeah
Cowabunga dude all right so teenage
mutant ninja turtles mutant Mayhem have
you seen it what did you think about it
or who's your favorite Ninja Turtle or
the one that you related most to whoever
it is whoever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more